[Musique]
le 20e siècle a bien sûr changé la
perception des possibilités qu'offre le
ballet nous avons tous compris que la
danse le corps pouvaient être non
seulement esthétique mais aussi une
incroyable source d'émotions c'est
d'ailleurs diaghilev qui a déclenché
tout cela au début du 20e siècle
il a introduit un nouveau ballet que la
russie ait aucun autre pays n'avait
jamais vu il a commencé à partir de zéro
c'est pourquoi notre art est unique
sans compter la culture russe c'est la
culture de la liberté c'est une culture
de grand sens et de grandes idées
c'est une culture sauvage c'est une
culture qui explose
[Musique]
le regard d'un chef d'orchestre exprime
presque tous les mains est parfois alors
qu'istres à recevoir ce signe rythmique
bon il faut jouer maintenant mais pour
savoir comment il faut jouer ce n'est
pas avec les mains c'est l'expression
des yeux du visage vous pouvez montrer
doucement ou au contraire montré alors
qu'istres qu'il faut plus d'énergie
tout est dans l'expression du visage
valeri guerguiev m'appelle un jour et me
dit écoute je t'en supplie il faut
immédiatement faire une nouvelle version
du casse noisette et en fin de compte
nous avons fait ce ballet qui fait salle
comble depuis déjà 20 ans le théâtre du
châtelet l'a sollicité deux fois ils ont
toujours d'authentiqués affiche de
diaghilev et nous y avons deux fois
présenter mon balai les français l'ont
tellement apprécié qu'ils ont demandé à
ce qu'on joue le casse-noisette deux
fois ruiz quelle est la force de la
russe et pourquoi l'occident si
intéresse-t-il autant chacun de ces
amateurs l'expliquent à sa manière mais
tout le monde évoque le
professionnalisme
l'assiduité sans fin le dévouement
demain ce qu'est le roi des souris a
transformé le prince en une poupée casse
noisette et celle l'amour peut rompre le
sortilège lui donnait une chance de
redevenir lui-même albinos dont je crois
dans cette histoire parce que quand on
danse
elle prend vie voilà pourquoi j'ai trois
joséphine à 8 ans aujourd'hui c'est une
des élèves les plus prometteuses de
l'école du ballet russe
bon
youssouf line dance joséphine d'orsay
dans une école de ballet aux pays bas
dans un groupe entre enfants de 4-5 ans
elle est dense et principalement des
rôles d'animaux
au près un jour je les emmener avec moi
pour voir une production hollandaise du
lac des cygnes
elle a été très impressionnée elle était
si fascinés qu'une fois à la maison elle
m'a annoncé
je veux aller dans une vraie école de
ballet et là j'ai commencé les
recherches
je cherchais un ballet qu'il soit
différent du néerlandais j'ai fini par
trouver l'académie de ballet la
classique russe avant d'envisager voulu
étudier à l'école de danse de ballet
russe
rask et le niveau y est bien plus élevé
je vais te faire notre esprit c'était
assez dur
je ne savais pas vraiment comment il
fallait faire parce que je n'étais pas
habitué à se situer à cette technique
elle était donc assez dure pour moi ça
vous ennuie ou formés
[Musique]
on
mais
[Musique]
c'est la chaîne et elle ne parlait pas
un mot d'anglais
cette chaire et je ne parlais pas du
tout irlandais il fallait littéralement
tout lui expliquer avec les mains elle
ne comprenait presque rien de ce que je
disais elle pouvait seulement comprendre
que l'on je bougeais et comment bouger
les autres joséphine ce n'est pas du
tout dans la ligne regarde suis ici et
là les 1000 à l'aligner dans les gens
c'était dur pour elle c'est vraiment
lourd comme travail un moment donné on
doit commencer à aimer à travailler dur
quel genre drame au temps où il
s'autoriser arrive à faire quelque chose
mais c'est dur elle se donne du mal et
s'énerve et tout cela leur arrive assez
souvent quand je tiens bon tu te mêles
commence petit à petit à aimer ça le
bide
c'est ce qu'on appelle chinaud la
persévérance il n'existe pas aux pays
bas il ya une école occidental tout des
tendances occidentales sont là rien mais
si nous voyons quelqu'un que je danse
bien il se dit il doit sûrement avoir un
professeur russe
ils voient ils perçoivent aux nuances du
bois où il peut vous mettre dans le
spectacle ce qu'il peut faire de vous
tapez les stones au tube stabilisés
routes et quand vous commencez à
travailler avec lui c'est là que vous
développez votre talent et awa winnik a
très bien plus haut encore plus haut
plus haut plus haut bien
et maintenant temps le genou et retourne
le talon en bas voilà le coup de pied
tendu aussi notre école principal se
trouve à saint pétersbourg et un jour
nous avons eu l'idée de créer une
filiale de l'école de saint pétersbourg
en bas et a grandi et en bas en bas
cette année nous avons trois
anniversaires le premier et à saint
pétersbourg les 25 ans de l'école canton
et les cinq ans de la fondation anna
pavlova ici c'est la fondation qui a
créé l'école de ballet de ballet
classique russe
ici à la haye et puis il y à
l'anniversaire de ma danseuse de ballet
préféré la plus cool il sonne à dire
rouge basse et nadia à 15 ans c'est une
retraitée
personne ne peut la remplacer maintenant
parce que dans les cercles canin c'est
une ballerine réputé exceptionnel il se
voulait lui
[Musique]
avant je n'avais à danser quand elle
était jeune elle prenait part au
spectacle
mais maintenant c'est fini elle est à la
retraite nouveau traité on ne dirait pas
c'est le moment c'est un grand
anniversaire elle pourtant ne dirais pas
que c'est une retraitée
[Musique]
nous habitons juste derrière tatiana et
vladislav sont ensemble depuis 15 ans
elle a dansé au bolchoï pendant le
siècle d'or de grigorovitch et lui au
théâtre kirov dit mariinsky aujourd'hui
je vais mettre mes chaussons d'accord je
manque d'expérience on sent que ce n'est
pas notre spécialité
oui je n'ai pas assez de force
voilà ça va faire une belle séquence
c'est l'expérience de vol chez claas de
l'expérience de kirov notre expérience
dépasse la vôtre et c'était en 1993
nous nous préparions à produire le
casse-noisette je devais danser pour la
première fois les poupées russes dans la
chorégraphie de grigorovitch c'est un
numéro très difficile avec des sauts
compliqué il y avait un saut avec un
retournement il fallait atterrir dans
une grande pause sur la jambe haute à
l'atterrissage je suis tombé je me suis
cassé le genou déchirure de ligament ces
risques et c'est un tournant pour
quelqu'un de solide qui est déjà passé
par une école très sérieuse on fait des
exercices de 9 heures du matin à huit
heures du soir
mais même quand une personne est aussi
expérimentée elle comprend soudain que
la vie peut changer en l'espace d'une
seconde ce qui m'a poussé à apprendre le
métier d'enseignant
comme ça on n'y arrivera jamais encore
une fois hélas pas valérie
travaille-t-on coups de pierres valérie
n'y pense même pas elle n'essaie même
pas des chaussettes à la place des pieds
je fais ça depuis des années en fait ça
a été un moment effrayant
la première fois qu'on entre dans une
classe devant les enfants qu'on connaît
pas torkhani snack à pitas jeunesse
gazette
je ne savais ni quoi dire ni comment
parce qu'il vous scrutent tous il vous
regarde et vous attendent
ils veulent nous tester ils veulent
comprendre s'ils pourront vous dominez
ou non je n'ai jamais envie de me lever
parce que le matin j'ai vraiment sommeil
mais après je prends mon petit déjeuner
c'est déjà le moment d'y aller à l'école
les cours commencent à 8h30
je dois donc me lever assez tôt ils vont
en cours
ensuite une fois que les cours sont
finies il mange quelque chose vite fait
dans la voiture et après tout de suite
ils vont en classe de danse
tatiana n'aime pas qu'on soit retard
alors ma mère me coiffe et caetera et
après je vais
[Musique]
de longues journées de travail ont alors
commencé pour joséphine quatre jours par
semaine et d entraînement supplémentaire
le dimanche mais elle aime ça joséphine
adore ça
relance ait personne la russie a une
vraie culture du ballet alors que les
pays bas n'ont pas du tout cette culture
voilà pourquoi les écoles néerlandais
c'est de l'amateurisme
mais ce que nous avons vu à l'école de
tatiana et vladislas c'est un tout autre
monde le vrai monde du ballet
professionnels planète
une fois que clara auront peu de
sortilèges que le prince l'amène au
royaume des délices d'automne et la fée
dragée organise une grande fête
et puis quand elle se réveille elle se
demande si c'est un rêve ou la réalité
il n'aura jamais su elle n'aurait jamais
su si c'était un rêve ou la réalité
c'est l'essence de l'histoire et ça
c'est la boule de neige que j'ai reçu du
père noël
elle a une très jolie musique
normalement je fais les exercices ici je
fais tendu jeter un battement maman me
l'interdît mais je l'entends ici voici
ma chambre contenait les liens culturels
entre pays sont très importants les
relations politiques sont bien sûr
parfois bonne parfois un peu moins bonne
ce n'est pas très important
ce qui est important c'est la culture le
lien entre les peuples
d'amis
[Musique]
les tiges le prestige et la renommée de
nos traditions sont si importants que
malgré tous les scénarios politiques
malgré les nuages qui sont parfois un
obstacle à nos performances
les vrais artistes russes il est vrai
orchestre russe qui lèverait troupe de
ballet au troupe d'opéra les coeurs les
metteurs en scène comme les peintres les
maîtres de ballet les compositeurs vase
y est allé fort ont toujours du succès
parce qu'il ya une tradition trop
puissantes d'air en occident il ya
aujourd'hui un grand intérêt pour
l'avant-garde russe malevitch kandinsky
etc
j'avais même une caricature à ce sujet
ce carré noir comme une pierre tombale
pesant sur les peintres contemporains
même si j'adore malevitch comme vous le
comprenez bien l'avant garde russe c'est
aussi important que les icônes russes
[Musique]
il ya un énorme écart entre l'art
contemporain au danemark et l'art
contemporain en russie nous avons
beaucoup de peintres danemark
ils font principalement de la peinture
abstraite et peu d'entre eux sont bien
formés c'est ce qui fait la différence
avec la russie parce que tous les
peintres que nous exposons dans notre
galerie ont une très bonne formation
académique et s'ils connaissent bien et
savent tout faire ils peuvent prendre
n'importe quoi parce qu'il leur a fallu
apprendre dans le détail
voilà ce qui me plaît vraiment exposés
des peintres qui sont vraiment
talentueux qui sont les vrais maîtres de
leur profession ceux qui connaissent
diverses techniques
on qualifie les personnes comme guns de
propriétaires du sinn de journaux de
bateaux à vapeur
il a pendant de nombreuses années était
directeur de grandes entreprises
internationales et c'est aujourd'hui un
investisseur privé
en fait c'est arrivé quand j'ai
rencontré ma femme tatiana
c'était il ya onze ans elle m'a appris à
comprendre l'art parce que je n'avait
jusque là jamais été quelqu'un qui
fréquentent les galeries et s'intéresse
à la peinture elle m'en a beaucoup parlé
je suis né un saint pétersbourg
mon grand père m'a transmis cet amour
pour l'art secousse l'amour pour l'
architecture qu'à partir de mai quatre
ans il me montrait tout dans cette ville
il m'emmenait dans les musées vous allez
ont très souvent à l'ermitage au musée
russe
je me souviens parce qu'il me racontait
mais pour moi c'était un vrai bonheur de
me promener avec mon grand père
tatiana est quelqu'un qui ne s'arrête
jamais elle a créé la société de
l'amitié russo danoise elle a lancé une
école pour enfants avec l'enseignement
en russe elle continue de s'occuper de
projets liés à la reconstruction de
l'ermitage
j'ai ouvert cette galerie en 2015 pato
ici evgueni oui merci
je ne veux pas dire que j'avais l'idée
de devenir gallery sac ou de créer une
galerie en plus je savais que d'un marc
c'était difficile mais les circonstances
étaient telles que nous avons acheté ce
bâtiment c'était le bâtiment le plus
moche de la ville
après quand nous l'avons acheté nous
avons décidé tania dit c'est un
excellent endroit pour une galerie et je
me suis dit pourquoi pas faisons une
galerie à site web pour vous donner une
petite idée
le bâtiment ressemblait à ça quand nous
l'avons rachetée nous avons beaucoup
investi d'énormes sommes dans la
reconstruction de ce bâtiment et nous en
avons fait donc une galerie
professionnel je ne presque rien vu de
ce genre ici
[Musique]
nous avons voulu créer un endroit où
chacun puisse s'asseoir se détendre
écouter de la bonne musique venir avec
son ordinateur voire une tasse de café
et se délecter en même temps de belles
peintures
voilà pourquoi nous avons aussi une
cheminée un canapé ici les gens peuvent
s'asseoir et se reposer il est très
difficile de tenir une galerie il faut
beaucoup de publicité suffisamment pour
que les gens viennent chez nous tous les
peintres sont des professionnels c'est
ce qui fait la différence entre notre
galerie et les galeries danoise on me
propose par exemple d'exposer plus
d'artistes danois pour attirer
l'attention mais très souvent elles ne
me plaisent pas et quand on discute avec
mon mari de ce que nous voulions avoir
dans notre galerie nous voulons qu'elles
soient harmonieuses souvent quand je
regarde des peintures dans d'autres
endroits
je ne comprend tout simplement pas de
quoi il s'agit je me suis souvent
demandé est ce que l'on peut considérer
ça comme de l'art et si je réponds non
nous ne l'emportons pas quand on va dans
de grandes expositions
on s'y sent mal le champ énergétique est
déstabilisé voilà pourquoi elle est très
difficile d'expliquer quelque chose
les gens doivent comprendre comment on
mélange la couleur comment elles se
marient ils sont censés savoir les
choses comme ça mais ils croient qu'ils
n'ont pas besoin pour l'essentiel est de
créer
par exemple chez nous au danemark il y à
un chanteur célèbre qui est aussi
peintre il travaille dans le style pop
arty ses oeuvres sont vendus à des prix
très élevés il les vend moins cinquante
mille couronnes danoises c'est beaucoup
d'argent sur les forêts
[Musique]
j'ai travaillé pendant plus de vingt ans
à l'ermitage mais la paire istres khama
a mené loin des frontières de ma patrie
snhf
c'est compliqué de sacrifier tout impayé
toute une vie pour une seule personne
il se peut qu'il s'agisse de personnes
très belle d'une personne excellente et
c'est peu qu'elle ait de l'amour entre
vous mais c'est d'un monde tout à fait
différent et c'est très compliqué
[Musique]
ilike j'aime cuisiner ces rames du
hockey
[Musique]
nous avons fait connaissance sur
internet sur un site de rencontres pour
amateurs de golf
nous nous sommes rencontrés nous avons
fait une partie de golf pour discuter et
mieux nous connaître
plus tard nous avons décidé de vivre
ensemble et ça fait plus de dix ans que
nous vivons ensemble
elle venait de fêter son 60e
anniversaire quand elle est allée à la
conquête du mont blanc avec ses amis
russes qui vivent en allemagne
il avait à peu près le même âge que
tatiana ils ont donc décidé de faire
l'ascension du mont blanc
alors je me suis dit que ça devait être
une femme digne d'intérêt parce que nous
n'avons pas de montagne au danemark
je vais dire quelque chose
d'abord par bienvenue à tous dans notre
galerie on nous a mis beaucoup vous voir
ici
nous sommes très heureux de vous voir et
aujourd'hui c'est l'ouverture d'une
petite exposition comme evgeni est en
charge de cette exposition
je n'ai le temps pour rien je viens
d'arriver
voilà pourquoi je ne le temps pour rien
faire je suis obligé de tout faire au
dernier moment
généralement ne sont prêts pour les
expositions vostok
[Musique]
cher mais là il est malade il ne parle
plus mais nous présentons sa collection
notre galerie ne rapporte pas du tout
d'argent pas quand mais tant que ça nous
intéresse nous allons la garder pour
nous c'est un style de vie différent et
ça nous plaît nous avons une règle dans
notre galerie
si vous avez acheté un tableau que vous
l'avez emporté chez vous et qu'au bout
d'un certain temps vous vous dites non
il ne me plaît plus n'est pas à ça que
je m'attendais bien vous pouvez leur
apporter et acheter quelque chose
d'autre
génial je n'ai pas vu un seul d'un mois
à venir ici et dire ce n'est pas
intéressant
ils disent tous pros c'est tellement
intéressant c'est tellement beau oui
cette fois la wii s'est vendu la
totalité
oui les trois très bien revenez nous
voir
[Musique]
tatiana ne cherche pas le profit elle se
tient à l équilibre elle n'expose et
neuf ans que ce que peut acheter un
danois ordinaire qui s'intéressent à la
russe l'ania ski très bien et elle a un
certificat d'instructeur de ski elle m'a
appris à skier quand j'avais 60 ans
beaucoup de gens me disaient c'est
dangereux à ton âge tu es gros et tu
pèse trop lourd
on ne fait pas ça tu vas te casser une
jambe mais tanya m'a appris une
technique tout à fait sûrs et maintenant
je peux skier partout je ne skie certes
pas aussi vite qu'elle mais d'ici
quelques années j'espère que je pourrai
skié comme je l'entends
[Musique]
tatiana à des méthodes de conviction
qu'elle maîtrise parfaitement
il n'existe pas de barrière qu'elle ne
pourrait franchir quand il m'a vu skier
il m'a donné un nouveau petit nom alpina
ballerines à albina ballerina parce que
je lui ai appris à skier à 60 ans et
désormais elle fait très bien jusqu'ici
tatiana jusqu'à alpina ballerina je
t'aime il me le dit plusieurs fois par
jour et en eau grâce dit
[Musique]
les gens créatifs doit vivre dans la
forêt voilà pourquoi tatiana immo games
ont choisi cet îlot en pleine nature
maya il m'appelle ma petite fée des bois
parce qu'ils croient que je sais une
feuilleton fille maintenant qu'il sait
que je suis je le fais il rêve de
devenir entre un charmant il me dit en
danois être fille je veux devenir en
tranches armand ceara sur la fiche
il est fantastique j'ai encore chaque
jour nous lisons dieu merci en plusieurs
fois
d'abord dans la piscine le matin merci
et lui ai dit aussi dieu merci de nous
être rencontrés sur cette terre
d'accord je l'appelle ma vieille et
parfois ma mignonne fée des bois
l'objectif principal est de mettre en
avant notre art je trouve alors qu'on en
parle qu'on connaisse le peintre tout le
monde me disait que c'était difficile je
vous moi je répondais c'est pas grave
j'admire les gens de talent j'en connais
beaucoup je veux parler de les mettre en
avant
nous sommes comme des ambassadeurs dans
ce pays
nous voudrions développer cette niche
dans laquelle nous travaillons au
danemark et en europe promouvoir divers
pains nous croyons que c'est un très bon
investissement est fier qu'on perd si
vous comparez le prix et la qualité
la russe un grand avantage parce que les
tableaux de bonne qualité sont vendus à
des prix modérés
[Musique]
m
à venir je ne roule bien sûr nous
voulons promouvoir notre art qu'est ce
que nous avons une école formidable
c'est l'une des rares qui reste dans le
monde
[Musique]
e
il y attend aussi crétacé rôle au score
le secret purement russe n'existe pas à
l'oscar classique mais si une création
russe oui atteint les sommets de l'art
14 très peu de gens dans le monde
la ligne peuvent rivaliser me digne et
ses ennemis
[Musique]
la situation des peintres est très
difficile vous voyez aujourd'hui la
notion de professionnalisme ou bien
celle de bons coloriste aux deux bons
dessinateurs n'existe pas puisque
aujourd'hui les peintres ne savent pas
peindre
un bon signe et qu'aujourd'hui on achète
des tableaux des réalistes socialistes
qui le méritent et les prix sont élevés
ce qu'ils méritent aussi le réalisme
socialiste a connu beaucoup d'excellents
artistes
voici une oeuvre qui m'impressionne
beaucoup
elle s'appelle les jours de travail les
gens recevaient des graines pour
salaires voilà ce qu'ils ont récoltées
et ils répartissent tout ça ils sont
joyeux habillé pour un jour de fête
ils vont recevoir des graines pour
légion de travail et n'auront pas faim
en plus d'être un grand entrepreneur et
président de la fédération russe des
échecs
andreï filatov possède la plus grande
collection privée d'art soviétique
on a eu l'idée au regard de toutes les
collections qui ont été emportées à
l'étranger dans les années 90 de les
acheter de les réunir dans une
collection et les montrer au monde
entier
je me souviens de la première exposition
au moyen-orient
quand nous avons apporté de l'art
soviétique c'était prévu pour un mois
mais en fin de compte elle a duré quatre
mois et faisait salle comble nous les
gens venaient du monde entier avec
beaucoup d'admiration pour connaître
l'art soviétique au mieux j'ai vu des
gens pleurer près des tableaux j'étais
sous le choc et après l'idée est venue
de mettre en avant notre art via les
échecs et le vent du nord
[Musique]
la corrélation entre entre l'art la
réalisation d'un grand vin elle peut se
faire grâce à deux points le premier
c'est tout d'abord avoir une bonne
maîtrise technique et la deuxième chose
c'est
aimer ce que l'on ce que l'on fait
bien entendu on doit également y mettre
doit également y mettre son âme on doit
y mettre son coeur afin de favoriser le
résultat de très haute qualité en la fin
andrei aime sincèrement le vin et il
aime sincèrement l'art de botho strauss
3 il a décidé de créer le meilleur vin
au monde un compte chez avait une envie
mais honnêtement c'est ce qu'il aime
vraiment du teasing est en fait tout ce
qu'il fait il le fait avec sincérité et
honnêteté
[Musique]
l'idée d'exposer des étiquettes à
travers la bouteille est une idée
extraordinaire de
andreï filatov le propriétaire du
château cette bouteille est reprise sur
la bouteille ancestrale de saint-émilion
d'il ya 250 ans
j'ai vu cette forme de bouteille et
décidé de l'utiliser pour vous
l'idée de base était qu'elles soient sur
la table
la personne qui goûte le vin regarde les
étiquettes et commence à faire des
recherches sur le peintre a le goût
gueuler et l'année l'intérêt pour notre
art la personne ne joue pas uniquement
du vin mais elle a aussi une bonne
raison pour apprendre quelque chose sur
le peintre discuter autour de la table
et toi c'est très bien cela permet de
tout d'abord de pouvoir faire découvrir
des peintres russes travers un vin
français
ce vin français à travers le monde va
pouvoir faire découvrir également tous
les peintres
russe de la fondation cet été nous avons
eu une importante réussite
le célèbre footballeur david beckham a
commandé notre vin au restaurant la
petite maison à nice il lui a beaucoup
plu et à l'époque il logé chez elton
john soit c'est lui qui l'a dégustée
soit ils l'ont bien ensemble le
lendemain il a posté la bouteille vide
avec une peinture dorée pin sur
instagram et a écrit merci pour ce grand
vin 58 millions de personnes ont vu la
peinture dorée pin 17 octobre
nous avons des contrats avec les états
unis avec abu dhabi l'italie l'allemagne
le royaume uni
c'est assez vaste géographiquement
[Musique]
à
voilà le lieu sacré au ce
préparer aux semis lot le vin
pour les fermentations et
vous pouvez remarquer que c'est
également une
une belle pièce d'art avec
youri gagarine au centre du cuvier et
qui se reflète à travers les cuves en
inox
il faut souligner ce que nous avons de
plus grand ce qu'on a de plus grand
c'est gagarine
mais cette peinture a été la première
sur notre vin celui de l'année 2014
c'est avec celle ci qu'on a commencé le
projet la première bouteille porter
cette peinture je montre ce que j'aime
depuis l'enfance nous avons aussi une
grande musique tout y est et gagarine
rakhmaninov larchitecture la france
voilà pourquoi cela donne un bel effet
[Musique]
à
en rentrant dans le chai vous constatez
que la musique qui berce et qui éveille
notre vin est une musique du compositeur
rachmaninov
actuellement ce c'est notre millésime
2018 qui est élevé dans ces barriques de
bois de chêne
la musique ce sont des vibrations et
donc cette musique de rachmaninoff à lui
apporter un sont positifs durant tout
son sens élevage
en
s not so de la musique russe a quelque
chose de spécial d'unique qui touche le
coeur et martin a très bien dit que la
musique
il parlait certainement aussi de
lui-même bertand naissait dans le coeur
et aller vers le coeur est interdite
hier la musique c'est l'amour rv je
pense au delà qu'au fond d'eux mêmes
pour austin r quand les spectateurs
étrangers vont concerts d'artistes
russes ils le ressentent
c'est impossible de ne pas le ressentir
on n'est pas obligé de parler ou de
venir avec des pancartes
la musique n'a pas du tout besoin de
cela dit tous par elle-même elle entre
dans l'âme humaine
[Musique]
oui
la musique classique va aider l'élevage
du vin pendant ses 22 mois en barriques
il faut prendre du plaisir quand on voit
ce vin c'est déjà et quand on y goûte on
a envie d'y revenir
ça c'est très important
nous arrivons devant la cave des
millésimes où nous avons la
représentativité des douze étiquettes
pour chaque millésime sur les
collections 2014 2015 et 2016 étiquette
qui représente les tableaux de la
fondation art russe
trente mille bouteilles par an c'est le
volume total de production 70% sont
vendus en france
en france on aime la russie on aime
l'art russe beaucoup de français par
contre ne savent pas que chagall par
exemple est né dans l'empiré russe et a
grandi à vis des basques qui le
considèrent comme peintre français nos
peintres et sculpteurs d'aujourd'hui ont
un grand succès en occident il y a été
un grand intérêt dans le monde pour
notre armée
il y a des difficultés pour organiser
des expositions pour nos musées aux
états unis par exemple il ya donc une
compétition évidence le tableau d'un
impressionnistes français coûte
maintenant à peu près 150 millions
d'euros
un impressionniste soviétique coûte un
million d'euros cent cinquante fois
moins bien sûr que c'est injuste
ça ne sera pas comme ça très longtemps
les prix vont monter pour les uns aient
baissé pour les autres il ne peut pas y
avoir un tel écart tout est très
subjectif
chaque pays a ses préférences fils
[Musique]
le corps découpé en deux de first c'est
le port le plus cher au monde jusque là
une moitié a été vendue 5 millions de
livres donc l'ensemble du port fait 10
millions de livres c'est beaucoup plus
que 10 millions de dollars
nous avons une très grande famille
andrei a deux enfants de son premier
mariage
je peux d'analyser le gestion non si
nous en avons eu quatre ans semble le
plus grand à 5 ans et ce ne sont pas des
jumeaux
ils sont tous nés à un an d'écart les
filles aînées se sont katia et où il y
en a elles ont 14 et 8 ans les cadets se
sont lloris 5 ans vale ya trois ans vaz
ya deux ans et galina huit mois bon
c'est le père d'une famille nombreuse
andrée a toujours voulu une grande
famille moi aussi je voulais une grande
famille mais je n'aurais jamais pu
imaginer qu'il y en aurait autant je
suis incroyable mort ce qu'ils soient si
nombreux en bas valia une belle robe
comment tu fais des bisous valia qui
doucement il y a une importante
décoration la gloire maternelle je rêve
que ma femme en soit décoré pour ce
faire il faut avoir cette enfant ou plus
vous voyez un bisou un bisou bastien
mais si tu veux ou pas valia tu veux ou
pas tu veux tu veux tu veux que le chant
s'embrassent vallier embrase la lia tu
veux ou pas je veux il veut on a des
contraintes source comme nos enfants par
le russe français anglais et chinois
le chinois c'est le plus difficile pour
eux je crois mais nous avons décidé que
ce serait un grand avantage pour eux les
russes ne font jamais quoi ils ne se
rendent pas et ne cède jamais valia
c'est toi qui fait des bêtises ou
sébastia qui fait des bêtises chercher
sa relative à les hanches en chantant
petit n'avait chez nous c'est toujours
joyeux et bruyant le plus important dans
la maison c'est le rire des enfants mon
mari est un père formidable qu'il est au
courant de tout ce qui est important
dans la vie des enfants
les nouveaux admirateurs de katia les
réussites artistiques du liana il sait
tout sur les meilleurs amis de youri à
l'école un quota le niveau scolaire
il aime beaucoup ses enfants je pense
que c'est ce qu'il ya de plus important
dans sa vie sa maman papa
[Musique]
seuls deux producteurs en france
utilisent les armoiries de notre pays le
champagne cristal utilisent les
armoiries de l' empire russe parce que
nicolas ii a largement influencé le
design de la bouteille
les armoiries de l'union soviétique sont
utilisés sur notre vin
je suis né en union soviétique j'ai été
élevé par cette arme voilà pourquoi je
fais aujourd'hui tout ce que je peux
pour promouvoir l'art soviétique
l'exposition 20 échec puis le charme
dont nous avons organisé en 2012 le
championnat du monde d'échecs dans la
galerie tretiakov 5 millions de
personnes ont regardé la diffusion en
direct dans plus de 90 pays du monde le
symbole du match et et victor popkov et
son oeuvre intitulée la brigade fait une
pause maintenant on attend
[Musique]
anatoly karpov le deuxième champion du
monde
andrei vie la teuf président de la
fédération russe des échecs anatoli
karpov et non seulement le deuxième
champion du monde mais aussi le
président du conseil de tutelle de la
fédération d'échecs de la région de
sverdlovsk et aussi je suis le vice
président de la fédération russe des
échecs
tommy mon père m'a appris à jouer aux
c'était une passion d'enfance j'ai été
lié aux échecs presque toute ma vie
[Musique]
et on ne souffle pas les filles jouent
très bien mais elles sont déjà grande
katja yuliana du riz a commencé
récemment il ya six mois il est super
fort aux échecs
je veux simplement être champion du
monde léger uliana tu soutiens qui ils
ont ri ou katia patata et toi moi je
soutiens tout le monde voyait je
m'intéresse à tous j'aime apprendre
j'aime savoir des choses nouvelles
j'aime l'art j'aime tous courtois et si
papa est heureux et contents de me voir
jouer aux échecs
pourquoi ne pas donner un peu de joie
papa dont je pense que tu as quoi tu
penses je pense je pense kaihori oui oui
les échecs ne m'intéresse pas autant que
leur papa et collectionneur d'art c'est
ce domaine qui m'intéresse plus tôt mais
pas toujours préféré de la collection de
papa c'est le graveur et s'attaque au
sap co cette co parce que c'est la
peinture dont j'ai raconté l'histoire au
prochain lindsay tchad au pape avait
organisé une exposition allemande ont
fait tâche et que nous sommes approchés
de cette cause est le prince charles ne
comprenait pas du tout qui était ce
sakho qui est ce personnage unique tony
momoh personne de ceux qui étaient
présents ne pouvait expliquer clairement
qui a été sept comme quoi ça ni papa ni
l'ena notamment parce qu'il ne
comprenait pas tout simplement pas aller
moi justement j'avais étudié cette
oeuvre ce sujet une semaine plus tôt et
un poste je lui ai tout simplement
raconter la légende wasquehal et voilà
un peu chiant
[Musique]
la fameuse oeuvre de popkov s'appelle le
printemps ou dépôt c'est sa première
oeuvre importante réalisée en 1958 un
travailleur du dépôt aurait par des
roues idiot et voilà que passe une fille
à qui ils essaient de faire la cour elle
lui plaît
on voit sur cette peinture qui lui fait
la cour mais elle fait semblant de ne
pas y prêter attention
si il y à le symbole des feuilles de ce
printemps parce que l'amour né entre
deux on dirait que cette austère un
dépôt ferroviaire mais ici on ne voit
que le plus important dans la vie et
c'est l'amour
andrei a un sens artistique incroyable
histoire il comprend très bien l'art et
j'ai une complicité est en amour
incroyable avec lui en tout cas la carte
une île sans que ce tableau a de
l'énergie
il regarde la peinture et voit tout de
suite si c'est un chef-d'oeuvre ou par
un organisme pas eh oui c'est un talent
inouï au 1000m l'art et moi je laime
c'est là que nos intérêts convergent mon
pays ma moscou tué ma préférée voilà
hourra
aucun pays n'est épargné tout le monde a
des problèmes
les gens le ressentent très bien au
stade beaucoup en sont fatigués sont
fatigués de la politique et des guerres
de beaucoup de problèmes notre problème
balayés pour se gérer
malheureusement la politique influence
notre vie mais quand le spectateur
quitte à salles de concert il oublie
beaucoup de choses qui se passent dans
chaque pays quand on ne suce le trucage
des stades
[Musique]
ouais
c'est tout moi même j'ai dit à ma mère
dit comme je veux devenir danseuse
étoile elle accepté d'élever une famille
elle est tout à fait pour que je
devienne une danseuse professionnelle
novarina
bien dommage tant chez moi je pense que
toute mère veut que sa fille fasse de la
danse ayant fait un nom joséphine
travaille beaucoup la situation au japon
elle a déjà une base technique très
solide à ça mais ça lui permet je pense
pour bientôt a commencé à apprendre les
rôles titres dans les spectacles il est
ce courrier qui était naturel de
jeamille bittar
dans doute ce nouveau contretemps dans
la représentation elle donne tout ce
qu'elle a pour être la meilleure
parfois en revenant derrière les
coulisses elle me dit c'est tout s'est
très bien passé j'ai très bien danser et
après pour vient tatiana jeudi par
exemple au bain ça n'allait pas et ça
non plus l'autre n était alors tout son
monde s'écroule en outre averti
oui pour atteindre ce niveau il faut
beaucoup travailler nos têtes
[Musique]
je ne voulais pas dans ce rôle parce que
j'étais trop petit je ne voulais pas
sembler un garçon mais maintenant je
comprends vraiment que casse noisette
c'est un grand rôle l'un des plus
importants
[Musique]
ce spectacle existe déjà depuis plus de
130 ans si on compte depuis sa première
au théâtre mariinski de saint
pétersbourg
on croyait alors au miracle qui se
déroulait sur scène on y croit encore
toujours
[Musique]
un soudanais où elle ne danse très bien
elle est très très bien damas lorsque
les six petites on disait c'est vraiment
un petit casse noisette broncher
[Applaudissements]
harmony of hand and mail son mode de
réflexion a changé elle s'est
transformée de la petite fille qui
jouait aux baleines en une vraie
danseuse de ballet professionnels danse
déjà le rôle de casse noisette avec un
grand plaisir
elle a mis beaucoup de temps à
s'habituer à danser avec un masque et à
ne pas être une belle danseuse dans un
bus
[Musique]
joséphine doit prouver ses compétences
au moins une fois par an dans le cadre
d'un concours et chaque fois qu'elle est
sur scène elle ne peut pas s'arrêter
comme les enfants hollande et ne dansent
pas comme ça il n'y a pas d'enfant qui
danse comme ça joséphine a remporté le
premier prix dans son groupe d'âge au
concours anna pavlova ici aux pays bas
allah est donc la première place vers
l'ouest bonjour comment allez vous
très bien
le monde du ballet peut souvent être
cruel parfois joséphine a des
difficultés parce qu'elle s'entraîne
beaucoup et travaille sur beaucoup de
rôles différents
pourquoi a comme ça pour le spectacle
maintenant joséphine rêve de devenir
danseuse de ballet je pense que cet
excédent qu'elle puisse poursuivre son
rêve et le chemin d'une carrière d'une
danseuse de ballet professionnels je
sais que le chemin sera difficile semé
d'embûches mais nous voulons la soutenir
sur ce chemin pour qu'elle puisse se
développer dans cette direction et rina
je ne sais pas ce que l'avenir nous
apportera et quand je veux juste qu'elle
puisse se consacrer longtemps au ballet
[Musique]
tatiana tatiana et vladislav sont si
gentils par les secours c'est pourquoi
j'aime cette école de danse parfois
quand nous faisons de la gymnastique à
l'école ce qu'on me demande de faire le
grand écart ou de montella gens très
haut
et si certains garçons ils sont vraiment
drôles parce qu'ils essaient de faire
des écarts et saute
bien
[Musique]
dans ce cas à l'école russe et demandé
le parking les russes dansent dans tous
les théâtres du monde et danse mieux que
tout le monde
le pays bas n'est pas un pays du ballet
classique par exemple au théâtre royal
d'amsterdam les solistes principaux sont
anna tzigane kova mon ancien collègue du
bolchoï à now
les solistes principal de krasnoïarsk et
après l'ex solistes du théâtre
stanislavski à moscou l'école russe elle
est très demandé et si aux pays bas les
solistes principaux sont nôtres sa liste
[Musique]
c'est une mission particulière nous
portons notre culture nos âmes on va
dans des pays
c'est un genre de choc des cultures vous
voyez et on s'attend à ce qu'on nous
jette des tomates au visage et à la fin
on voit la salle debout à crier bravo
les russes et voilà voilà ce qui se
passe après ils sortent il recommence
encore assez russe boum boum boum
et voilà il se lève ils oublient tous
les russes bravo bravo les russes
[Musique]
rod qui avait cette idée que parfois la
maîtrise complotent contre l'âme
[Musique]
vous devez ressentir ça vous devez être
attentif
on essaye ici c'est la même chose vous
écouter seulement
ni sur business
ces business ce n'est pas tout pour nous
pas du tout nous faisons beaucoup de
choses différemment maintenant je suis
heureux que les saisons russes et repris
en plus j'ai une partie de ma famille
habite à paris et se rend parfaitement
compte de ce qu était à l'époque les
saisons russes de diaghilev et c'est
juste grâce aux affiches historiques qui
ont été conservés je me souviens qu'il
reste des affiches des spectacles de
diaghilev au théâtre du châtelet à paris
des châtelets des affiches absolument
époustouflante
[Musique]
oh